star wars visions
is going to be an exciting anime
anthology series
coming to disney plus in september
japanese animation
inspired a lot of the people at
lucasfilm over the years
we loved the idea of seeing star wars
expressed in that way
each one of these studios that we
approached we found hardcore star wars
fans
they all had a story they wanted
[Music]
[Music]
we were looking for something from the
heart and soul of the individual
creators
they are their visions to the lens of
star wars
there are so many genres at play
big and bold romantic and sweeping funny
comedic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we tried to have some retro vintage
feeling we couldn't skip the asteroid
influence people loved us trouble
[Music]
foreign
my we feel so fortunate
to be working with these filmmakers
there's so many opportunities
to reflect japanese storytelling in a
star wars
universe star wars visions
is completely different than everything
else in star wars storytelling
audiences will fall in love with it
[Music]
you